rank of row and by the way just as an aside notice how often we're reaching for the spectral theorem at this point
it's an incredibly handy tool and in fact we'd be lost without it anyway now that we have a spectral
composition row we can compute Schmid decompositions of our two vectors just like before and they're going to be
almost exactly the same the coefficients and the X vectors are the same because they come from the spectral decomposition of the reduced state which
is the same for both vectors the only difference is that we may get different vectors for the second system for the
first Vector which is s we'll get one set of vectors y0 through y Rus one and for the second Vector which is f we'll
get a POS possibly different collection which we can call z0 through zrus one so we now have schmitti compositions
for our two vectors which look very similar except that the vectors for the second system may be different but these
are Schmitty compositions so these two collections are both orthonormal and so we can simply choose
a unitary Matrix U that sends ya to Za for each a you can always do that unitary
operations are in fact equivalent to linear maps that transform one orthonormal basis into another and if
these two sets don't happen to span the entire space corresponding to Y we can always extend them both to orthonormal
Bases using coincidentally the gr Schmid orthogonalization procedure and that is how the unitary
equivalence of purifications is proved in lesson four of the series we discussed the superdense coding protocol
which allows a sender to transmit two classical bits to a receiver by sending one cubit at the cost of one ebit of
shared entanglement so I'm assuming that you're already familiar with that protocol and the point of this example is to briefly
explain how it connects to the unitary equivalence of purifications remember that the way that
the protocol works is that Alice and Bob share an ebit or in other words a five plus Bell State Alice chooses to transform that
Bell State into any of the Four Bell States depending on the two bits that she wants to send and then she sends her
Cubit to Bob and he measures to see which Bell State he has notice that all four bell States
give us the same reduced state for Bob's Cubit which is the completely mixed state and in fact that's already enough
to conclude that super dense cating is possible all four bell States purify the completely mixed state so by the unitary
equivalence of purifications we know that it must be possible for Alice to transform the five plus Bell State into
of the others by applying some unitary operation to her Cubit of course it's not difficult to come up with unitary operations that
actually work and they're very simple but it's interesting nevertheless that we can reach the conclusion that this is
possible without even thinking about the unitary operations themselves and moreover we can conclude
that generalizations of superdense coding to larger systems are possible provided that we have some way of generalizing the Bell states to larger
systems so that they all give the completely mix State as Bob's reduce State and there are in fact different known ways to do
that a different setting to which the unitary equivalence of purifications has implications is quantum
cryptography and one of its most important implications is that it rules out the existence of an unconditionally secure Quantum protocol for a
cryptographic primitive known as bit commitment so what is bit commitment bit commitment is an example
of a cryptographic ative by which we mean a low-level task or procedure that provides some basic functionality which
can then be used as a building block to do more interesting things like creating digital signature schemes or building
zero knowledge protocols for instance in the case of bit commitment the basic functionality is that one
player Alice is able to commit to a binary value of her choice to a second player Bob but her choice remains hidden
until she chooses to reveal it we require two specific properties from a protocol that implements bit
commitment it must be binding which means that Alice can't change her mind once she's committed to a bit and it
must be concealing which means that Bob can't determine Alice's bit until she chooses to reveal
it so it would be pretty nice to be able to implement this primitive using Quantum information because it's a
useful primitive but without any additional assumptions it turns out to be impossible possible to do it perfectly with Quantum information or even close
to perfectly and the unitary equivalence of purifications reveals that the idea at a very high level is
that if there were a Quantum protocol for bit commitment then there would have to be a so-called purified version of that protocol where we can imagine that
Alice has a system a bob has a system B and after the commitment is made but before Alice reveals the pair AB is in
one of two pure States size zero or I one depending on the bit that Alice
commits if the protocol is perfectly concealing then it must be that Bob can't tell the difference between the
two commitments so his reduceed state must be the same for the two possibilities however that implies by
the unitary equivalence of purifications that Alice can transform either one into the other by applying some unitary
operation to a alone so the protocol completely failed to be binding there are details in there that
I've swept under the rug but the heart of the matter is that the unitary equivalence of purifications tells us that this primitive is not something
that we can reliably Implement using Quantum information without additional assumptions of some
kind the last example of an implication of the unitary equivalence of purifications is a theorem known as the
Houston Joseph wooders theorem or hjw theorem for short let's start with a statement of
the theorem itself and this is a slightly simplified version of it just to avoid some technicalities so that we can focus on the main
ideas suppose that X and Y are systems and F is any Quantum State Vector representing a pure state of the pair
XY and now suppose that we think about the reduced state of the system X alone and we come up with any way that we
choose to express this reduced State as a convex combination of pure States as is shown on the screen
so for instance the number capital N in this expression which is the number of pure States we're averaging over could
be arbitrarily large possibly much larger than the dimension of the space corresponding to X or to Y for that
matter and what the theorem tells us is that there must exist a measurement on the system y having n outcomes such that
the following happens when the system Y is measured first each measurement outcome
appears with probability exactly equal to the corresponding probability in our expression of the reduced state of X as